at first I was going to criticize this
because why would a robot make the same
mistake as hundreds or thousands of
monologuing movie villains but then I
thought about how she was programmed she
specifically mentions her and Gemma
talking about books and music so who's
to say that she wasn't also trained on
movies and TV maybe Megan is just trying
to replicate what she thinks a human
would do based on that in any event she
doesn't realize that Katie is wearing
the haptic gloves that control Bruce
Gem's College robotics project who is
much larger than she is I guess Megan
doesn't have James Cameron's aliens on
her hard drive Bruce thrashes her around
and tears her in half but even that is
not enough to end it since the CPU is
located in Megan's head to make things
worse Bruce loses balance and falls on
Gemma giving Megan a straight shot to
get revenge on Katie me turn off oh I'm
afraid that won't work anymore Katie I
have a new primary user now me you know
I kind of love that for her however